people should go see a film like
deepwater horizon in a movie theater
it's a big intense experiential film hey
how you doing man if you go see it in
imax environment it's even more intense
sound design the set design the editing
the overall scope of the movie will
absolutely blow you away
some very very big sequences the oil rig
is about the size of a football field
and it blows up
and the rake deconstructs in front of
our eyes well character that Mark
Wahlberg plays Mike Williams was the
last one off that rig and it will one
o'clock in the morning he jumped 150
feet into the burning ocean we wanted
the audience to go in and jump with him
we make those that have a visceral
action component so rather than letting
I'd sort of sit back and watch this
happen trying to whatever you can clip
the audience in it so they don't feel
entirely safe Mayday Mayday this is to
provide vin
and that intensity being able to put an
item selection on traumatic experience
when they then disengage from it into a
more emotional experience we are seeing
characters holding each other helping
each other crying with each other is all
that more intense because the visceral
part was intense
those students on an imax obviously are
just going to be more visceral more
intense because that's the nature of the
imax experience
we do pg-13
you